Welcome to Stanford Graduate School of
Business. Follow our MSx students as they
take you on a 360 degree tour of student
and family residences. We have a breadth
of on-campus housing options to fit your
family as well as your lifestyle. Our
first stop is Escondido Village
primarily serving MSx, MBA, and other
graduate student families. Here's Carlos
who lives here with his wife Dora and
their three children.
Hey, good morning. I'm Carlos. I'm an MSx student at the Graduate
School of Business here at Stanford and
this is my house. We live in Escondido Village, which is five minute bike
ride to the School of Business and
right now I'm taking my little one to
the daycare. Let's go. Escondido Village
houses more than 4000 graduate students
and their families. With a vibrant
community of students, partners, and
children, there are numerous nearby
playgrounds and on-campus daycare and
schooling options. Plus it's only a
10-minute walk to the business school.
Next, follow Huimin, who lives in Munger
Graduate Residences. Munger offers studios
and one, two, and four bedroom apartments.
Munger houses 600 graduate students and
their partners across all disciplines
and graduate schools at Stanford. It's
contemporary design emphasizes open
common areas, community, and
cross-disciplinary discussion. Huimin
lives in one of the two bedroom
apartments. These furnished apartments
offer generous square footage private,
bathrooms, and full sized kitchens.
So here we are at my dorm at Munger Residence. What I love about Munger is that we have a
big community of students from many
different schools. Here
we have all sorts of social activities
including tea time, barbecue and movie time. My favorite is tea time. Munger is a short seven minute walk to
the business school and it's never a bad
walk considering we have 261 days of
sunshine every year. Even closer are the
GSB residences – they offer individual
rooms and kitchens shared by two rooms.
Meet Rob who lives at Jack McDonald Hall
which is part of GSB residences. Oh hey
there. I'm Rob, now a part of the MSx
program here In Jack McDonald Hall. This is a great place to live and it's
also great to be right across from the
GSB where you get to tap into the
wonderful MSx and broader GSB
communities. Anyway I got to run right
now and play some pool but I'll catch up
with you guys later. All residences have
communal and social spaces for students
to unwind, connect, and organize
activities. No matter where you live on
Stanford's campus you'll be part of a
vibrant community and form strong
friendships that will last a lifetime.